ever had a man criti
black Peggy like oh that Christ would
make you like yeah yeah how how did that
make you feel
going well
you've never had that I've had guys like
cry in front of me but not beg me to
stay not cry me like please
baby please no go on pal tell your story
go ahead
um no I just I did that yeah that's
that's happened to me
um did it make you look at him any
differently
oh this is gonna make me look bad nobody
should no no no it's fine
um
it's not really attractive to have a guy
like like crying and begging for you to
come back you know what I mean like
women don't want a man that needs you as
you know you know that probably doesn't
make me look the best yeah but I'm just
being honest like we don't want a guy
that falls apart if we're not in the
their life like the only guy that's fine
without us and we know we can like
depend on so if you're like crying and
begging for us back it's like it's not
attractive to us typically told that to
the guy that's boiling in it but you
know that you feel like your whole life
is gone like hang on I want to hear from
the ladies that have happened to you
um yeah I actually kind of liked it I
don't know I I thought it was
um
I thought is shared like strength that
you know he could share emotion to me
and obviously not like begging me but
like crying and being like you know I
actually love you like you know I want
to make this work like and he got tears
in his eyes and I kind of liked it yeah
did you get back with him
um no but
um
that's a great show that was a fantastic
show
well nobody begged but like I'm a empath
so I feel the people's emotions so you
know if the guy cries I cry you know so
it's like come and cry all together
because you know we you know
you know I like all the people and
that's the thing it doesn't matter break
up or not they all lost some people and
all the guys the awesome people and
everybody cry everybody has the same
emotions as women you know and we all
share the same things and so many
different things and you know
everybody's inspiring and everybody's
like
unique I think guys have the same
emotions as women
uh
in the long run deep down
yeah we all have the same emotions it
just like depends like some emotions
it's like
hidden some of motion small active so
emotions like we can show usually we
keep our Poker Face you know when we
don't want to show any emotions you
don't think women are more emotional
than men by and large I do I do I do I
do I do visibly emotional I think I
think we get deep we don't you know we
don't express it enough do you know what
I think guys cry like that or it affects
guys so much because I think guys love
idealistically
and I think women love opportunistically
elaborate on that I think women love you
based on the opportunity to love you
and
they're always looking for a better
opportunity to love somebody else hence
the monkey brunch and hence the reason
why when when the divorce has happened
you know she's got someone just there
whereas guys love idealistically when
they fall in love they're like this is
it done this is me for the rest of my
life I'm gonna live all my years out and
this is gonna be me and I think it
affects guys psychologically more so
than it does women well that's what they
say about women that they wait at the
finish line and [ __ ] the winners yeah
yeah and and it's unfortunate but it's
it's true I mean if the number one
reason
um for divorce or one of the number one
reasons is financial because you can't
act like that's not true yeah and like
like just being honest how long are you
gonna if a dude loses his job how long
are you staying how long is he not
working but a girl could lose her job
and he's gonna support her 100 where
it's like I mean you know you could and
even mental they'll stay with a fat
chick too I have a question for the men
if you're in a situation where you
uh like both of you are working your
wife or girlfriend whatever the
situation is and you end up losing your
job would you feel
demasculated or will you feel weird
having a woman provide for you until you
are able to yeah so suddenly like one
that's a pride thing but two has also
been instilled like mom always made to
be known like yo don't don't let no one
do for you that way they can't say
nothing on the front in your face when
they do get emotional feel some type of
way so in that sense like yeah
do you know I actually learned the hard
way with that
um it's very interesting a few years
back when I was you know in a
relationship
um I was a
Sole Provider for the relationship and
the and the family and um I got laid off
of my job and I was
um I was actually yeah I didn't have a
job for like three months and I remember
I specifically remember always being the
breadwinner of any relationship that
I've been in
and I'd been like with this one for like
six years and it had been three months
and the switch in her attitude within
that three months really surprised me
I was just like I'm provided in six
years like just chill the [ __ ] out you
know what I mean it's like like you're
acting like I'm some [ __ ] bum or some
[ __ ] don't worry I'll get another job
but it's like oh but we need this and
this and you're supposed to be in this
and I was like why it's only been
[ __ ] three
and that's what I realized you know what
yeah women are very interesting
creatures do you know do you know I
think some it kind of plays into I think
when girls are like um in a relationship
I think they watch other girls in
relationships
and compared their relationship to that
other relationship you've not seen the
bads in that relationship of course not
because that that girl's not going to
show you that you know what I mean so
that image what like I'll say like you
know girls are like oh Sierra Russell
Wilson they're like they were one they
all want that what they never show you
what's what's their bad issues until
they break up and then they'll be like
oh what did he do to her what did she do
I mean but all the time now is I want to
be like that relationship I want to have
that relationship probably you've got
that relationship but you left it well I
hear what you're saying women look at
all of these you know Beyonce and
Jay-Z's and Rihanna's and whoever's
they're they're with and do relationship
goals yeah and all that kind of stuff so
it's it's a women like idolizing
relationships and it's like one of the
reasons why relationships break down is
because women are looking at other
people's relationships expecting it to
be like that then when they get there
it's like well Rihanna did this with
ASAP Rocky you know what I mean he's not
taking me
he didn't buy me one thousand roses
how dare he
no I think I think most is more simpier
than that go on do you know what I mean
like you know how certain times like you
know say treat them mean keep them Keen
it would be like some people's Mantra
like how they do their things and then
some that girl she wants to be with the
guy that she thinks is going to be like
Russell Wilson so he's supposed to be
nice tall attractive
but still be like Prince Charming don't
step out wrong don't say anything wrong
Russell Wilson is a Sim though to be
honest no but even if he was a Sim like
I can't really say he's a sympathy if
he's got bare money no of course you can
he's simping for Sierra
Sierra is currently twerking on the top
of cars bro that's a that's a lack of
respect that she has for him
and so he's simping because he's
accepting that right wait what what's
the definition of you look for sin pin
then all right all right first of all
look Sierra was a single mother when he
got with her right features baby she's
got she's got one of the most notorious
like like
the modern day like pimps babies right
and she's gone from him to Russell
Wilson some nice clean cut dude like and
you're taking care of The Pimps baby
the reason why I'm saying that because
I've been there I'm saying like I've
I've taken care of another man's child
which I'm saying so I know what it's
like to be like you know what like
there's no benefit here were you
something yeah of course okay the thing
is
Is 2020 this is a thing like you I I
believe like you've got to learn from
your your life your the things that you
experience in life and it's like yeah of
course I've been I think every man's
been a SIM for a woman at some point do
you think Russell will and Wilson could
afford to pay for Sierra's child of
course he can and not even think about
it yeah but that's what I mean when I
say the difference between sympathy but
the problem is it's time his time is
Super valuable and he has to spend time
emotionally investing in the kid right
like that's if anything you could argue
he spends more because his time is worth
so much
we're talking about Sierra he was a
musician she's also got her own money
she's also out there so we're not saying
we're not I'm not talking I'm not
comparing it as to that's my whole point
where where girls are comparing
themselves to Sierra and Russell Wilson
like they got their type of money they
could afford to live nice and cushy but
fair enough you know what I'm trying to
say it's not the same when you and your
little nine-to-five job working for
Tesco and you're like no I want that
kind of relationship it doesn't it
doesn't matter and some of these women's
eyes whether they're working at the
corner shop or they're working at Tesla
dealership making like great money
doesn't matter they see they see these
celebrities they see these famous people
doing XYZ and they're like if my man's
not doing that for me I don't want it
and that's just how it's how it's like
came about nowadays and it's just in
society if he's not paying and for this
pain for that I saw a video and it was
like if a man's not paying for my hair
which is like a thousand dollars a month
my nails 500 plus this that and third is
like no he can't he can't be with me and
it's like well what are you doing do you
can you afford all that as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible